welcome to your round five recap of the  sink filled cup the strongest chess  tournament in history here in st. Louis  we had an exciting day today we saw  veselin topalov win his game and world  champion magnus carlsen grind down  number two Levon Aronian but it's all  about fabulous fabiano the young Italian  player winning yet another game to win  five in a row something that rarely  happens in chess history he is off to an  epic beginning I couldn't have even  dreamed that I would start with a  perfect score the result might not show  it but all the games have been difficult  but in any case it's a fantastic start I  couldn't have imagined that I would do  something like this this is shaping up  to be an historic event be sure to join  us here in st. Louis for live coverage  of the sink filled cup at 150 central at  us chess champs calm